saves me
and after all
you're my head baby
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I don't need you to worry it's not good
I don't
start over ready I don't need you to
work for me cause I'm all right
I don't want you to tell me it's time to
go home
I don't care what you say anymore this
is hey babe
I'm sure you knew
more than I could chew
and him
you really that was a missed opportunity
it should have been I did it my hey babe
well no no I thought about
hey babe
yeah
hey babe baby
[Music]
so like I've like the emotion that I've
been trying to
articulate lately and and where I think
I'm feeling is conflicted not conflict
but conflicted I feel in many aspects of
my world from everything every it seems
like
everywhere everything I do from making a
decision to order food to
what to wear
it feels like
I have my feet in two places and I'm
straddling Two Worlds and what I need is
to pick a side
I've been trying to pick a side and
that's what leads to the depression
that's what leads to the anxiety is is
if you can just get to a place where you
can have two feet on either side of
whatever the fence May hold you will
inevitably be better even if you realize
you chose wrong at least you won't be
conflicted and being torn down the
middle you'll be whole
so is there anything happening to you
like that
no
okay
the tea training for
look at this guy
what the [ __ ]
oh my God
this is from official deflex one look at
this
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my
God look at that the flexibility is next
level
the timing of you
throughout that conversation
did you could you imagine your first day
back at the gym and that's what you
[ __ ] do
that's very difficult what he's doing by
the way
is that little Nas X
he's his he's he's
front over back
front over back he's
he's not hitting his nose he's
gonna wait until
it's like what's it driven steaks look
at the crack of his ass
it almost looks fake why is he doing it
the [ __ ] is he training for
where is his where are his balls in a
scenario look at his ass crack
I like the like off The Dome because I'm
just tired
if you're tired I have a suggestion I
really because my yeah my kid's not
sleeping
you're tired sleep regression you want
to do something to wake you up we got
the sauce
we got the hot sauce
the hot sauce the hot Ones hot sauce so
as you know from last week I was on hot
ones I told you that they gave me the
the three last dab sauces that are 10
out of 10 Scoville units on so this is
the screamers this is what they when
they do the interview these are the ones
at the very very very end and I took
them on the show I brought them and I
think we set it up we talked about doing
it
I will do it if you will do it I know
that like we were going to decide if we
were going to do it or not I've
experienced it it's not good I really
don't want to do it but
how long does it last
it depends how much you take I suppose
but it it it it lasts it lasts like
really hot like really really hot
maybe like 20 minutes plus 20 minutes
plus yeah but we'll have we we have to
take like milk or ice cream or something
like that do you have ice cream oh I
should have brought Mylanta with me we
have ice cream
I mean look you're gonna need it I don't
think there's any way we could do this
without ice cream or milk there's no way
I people do it on the show but I think
that's because they end on these and
then the interview's over and they kind
of just like
but like I don't has anyone ever done it
and it never it they didn't affect them
at all
you see people get through
doing the whole thing without even
taking a sip of water it's crazy when
you did the show today I have to ask if
you have any medical problems blood
pressure issues I might have yeah I
think they actually might have maybe I
know I have to do covert testing but
like but but the show if you ever watch
a show
there you go pimp if you ever watched
the show
um people a lot of people do really well
but I'm telling you like I don't know
how they do it because when I took maybe
because he told me Sean Evans told me
like you're really going from zero to
100 on this because you usually build to
it but out of the gate on Truth or dab
you just do the hottest one so I guess
that could have been a shock Factor
about why it was like so like killer but
did you ever see you ever watch any of
them something were good but one of the
most infamous ones was DJ Khaled was on
and it was in the beginning like
towards more in the beginning DJ Khaled
I don't know if the show had the
reputation it had yet okay and DJ Khaled
definitely didn't do any research and he
came on and everyone loves to get
interviewed about this game everybody
told you yeah and DJ Khaled came on he
like brushed it all off so badly and he
was like he was kind of like
um
he was kind of like like placate he was
kind of like talking not talking down
but like he didn't give the show there
like the kind of like the the respect it
was to be on it and then he just was
like no not eating anymore no one's ever
done that I don't think his people told
him like no this is a thing he goes all
the through it's a good promotional tool
like he asks great questions and he he
it starts off with Tabasco and he ate
the Tabasco and he goes what are you
kidding me he goes anymore he ate
Tabasco sauce and that's it and then he
was like no I can't do this I can't do
this and it's it's one of the most
watched ones because he was such a he
was it was so he was so lame because I
am not good with spice
well then this is not for you this is
the hottest spice you could possibly
have
pimp you're not gonna do it right uh
I'll taste one of them why not you will
do it but I feel like you're the one
steering the ship and if we all have it
we might crash it'd be a fun ship but I
should sink they want to watch it thanks
guys what do we need we need cops we
need spoons I got chips you can put it
on the chips are we doing are we doing
all three of them we're just doing one
I can't do all three I don't think I can
I think there I think they're all on on
the bottle it says the level of heat
these all say 10 out of 10 Heat
the they're the last dab so it's like
the one that ends the interview
um the last day of Apollo is the world's
only hot sauce made with the Apollo
pepper the new hottest pepper from
Guinness World Record holding chili
breeders smoking that Curry the Apollo
pepper channels the sun's energy to
bring new levels of flavor and heat to
the world the sun's energy
caution the hottest sauce on hot ones
cranks the spice levels even higher with
this special triple x rated version of
the last dab three distinct strains
pepper X chocolate pepperax and Peach
pepperax combine to smoke out the
celebrity guests and fans alike
dude you tell me which one you want to
do I don't know
will it wake me up
yeah I think I think oh you're going to
be awake
you're not gonna be tying
you're gonna you're gonna you you're not
gonna be able to you're not gonna be in
this state that you are now no way
you're gonna be sweating and I couldn't
I couldn't stand still I had to
literally shake my body because the the
heat has to manifest itself somehow I
couldn't physically take it now I told I
don't do well with spice either so if
you're like me it's not gonna be good so
I will tell you it's not going to be
enjoyable but it might be good for the
people that listen and watch
foreign
I mean they gave it to me I don't I
would never use this in in real life and
so people use this in real life or this
is just a thing to I asked Sean that I
told you I think he just said like well
they have so many now and I think some
of them are really delicious I think
this one is more just like a let me try
let me see if I can do this unless
you're someone that could eat spice I've
I've a friend from India that will drink
this like water right so what's his name
but
um uh yeah dude I mean look shout out to
hot ones shout out to first we Feast
they gave us this stuff it's kind of
like a little plug if you guys don't
know if you live in under a rock and you
don't know
um hot ones or or or or the last dab go
to the YouTube channel first we feast
and it's the it's a it's the best it's
it's like people answering uh great
interview questions while they're taking
the hottest sauce in the world it's just
like I know the combo of it is so
entertaining
I feel like you are
if you're doubting it you know maybe we
shouldn't do it
I'm down I just I just hate spice
well so so the thing is that is that is
just all this is It's just hot spice so
I mean are you gonna do it knowing that
you I'll do it if you do it but I I
don't know why I'm gonna do it because
you don't actually want to do it no it
wasn't fun and it hurt and it was bad
but here this this will help you feel
better hot peppers contain an alkaline
oil-based molecule called capsicin yeah
which capsules yeah which sneaky
triggers the temperature sensitive pain
receptors in your mouth even though the
molecule itself doesn't produce heat or
cause any real damage unless you really
overdo it
you can hit alkaline an oil-based
molecule
which sneakily triggers the temperature
sensitive receptors
even though the molecule itself doesn't
produce heat
but so what are we saying are we saying
that there's not real heat is in our
head
yeah no that's not true no it's not in
your head it's in the receptors of your
tongue
how to cool you all right how long does
dissipates in 15 minutes
what though
the burn from capsicism yeah but that's
any capsules caps in since
this is the ghost pepper X Ghost Pepper
so I let's just
if the food is really hot it may lead to
nausea or vomiting
can stimulate the production of gastric
mucus and temporary uh blow my nose my
eyes tearing sweating profusely
immediately immediately within a minute
oh
I don't want to do it
yeah that's why don't we do it why don't
we do it and play Mad Libs we're gonna
play Mad Libs last week
he laughed so hard
playing for the beginning
what is this this is hilarious
it's Woody from Toy Story dancing
like twerk look at this
it's so it's so realistic
someone in a woody outfit look at that
it's got like serious moves
[Music]
it's like erotic look at Minnie Mouse
come at the end
foreign
or it could be worse
I don't know what we're gonna feel after
just this we might want to do it more or
we might not want to do it more okay are
you biting from the hot sauce okay
ready yeah on three
okay one two three okay
to me
it hit me immediately
does that happen the last oh my God
hiccups
I got the hiccups immediately
I'm waiting for it to really get bad
Chris's first time
is there any milk left
is there enough milk
I can't do this again I already can't do
this again I swear to God
I swear to God I can't do this again
it's gonna get
did it even hit yet
I don't know why you get the hiccups
hiccups does it get worse from here
I think
[Music]
ah
I want to do another one and play Mad
Libs I can't do that again
Sal I'm not lying to you man it hurts so
bad and I feel like I can't breathe
imagine this how you die I see the house
only for the minute that second that's
in your mouth well you have to keep
eating ice cream then
um
no joke try not to eat the ice cream see
what happens to you
we never heard anything about your
Disney trip either
my Disney trip is it bad is it happen I
swear to God I I know that tell me at
home would be like oh they're rocking
and playing it up I I can't explain to
you how much pain I'm in right now and I
would trade anything in the world to get
rid of this pain and go back to just
being depressed
because it comes in it comes in stages
like my depression
thank you Jenny you're a cold-hearted
[ __ ]
genuinely
I can't that was from just dipping a
chip in it yeah
eat three Wings full
all right Pimp's gonna go in ah
um I want to try now
I'm gonna try another I can't I can't
honestly I know you guys did it and I
know and I don't care you guys to call
me [ __ ] I can't I can't do it any it
I'm in so much like
like I mean I would say severe pain
how much did you take
I took a decent amount I already feel it
no you can't drink the milk I'm not mad
milks for Headliners only
oh you feel it right down your throat oh
I love that they made it a way to
torture celebrities
foreign
it's hard to talk
I can't man I'll interview you imagine
doing three wings of that I can't that's
the thing I can't I don't care everybody
can trust me and call me I mean just get
in line everyone can roast me and say
that I'm a failure I would just say well
I guess I'll see you at dinner on Sunday
because that's what everyone says anyway
and I I
this is not I will tell you this this is
not helping with my depression it's
making me feel worse now
and kind of realizing that members of my
family are right
dude I'm get I'm actually getting a
headache
um I'll tell you something hiccups and a
headache
um
some people don't drink anything or do
anything they just let it sit I don't
know how you do that
it's like it's like it's like my mouth
is so hot that I'm freezing
because you're old Alexa changes name
due to Amazon related bullying yeah I
agree wait what happened the lady
changed your name
yeah because because every time she gets
called for dinner
the the fridge turns on
Sal listen
I have a headache I have the utmost
respect for what you do I I can't I dude
I can't either I'm just I'm just doing
it because
the ice cream but
trying to make good
I found a great clip last night from the
80s oh no 93 if you guys can watch it
corny what does my therapist always say
don't resist accept
it's like you always say to the
listeners surrender surrender
[Laughter]
what do one more with this one and then
lean back and as long as we possibly can
through the pain don't take ice cream or
milk or water see if you guys can go I
mean it might take 36
37 seconds
I couldn't do it I had to go to my land
to eight seconds in but like
even if we sit here and punch the couch
and scream and stuff let's see how long
we could do it if we can make it like a
minute
want to see if we can make in a minute
let's see if we can make in a minute
I have a pounding headache and my tongue
is burning right now yeah
all right can you get the hair out of
the cup
where's the cup oh yeah yeah if you just
get that hair out of the cup
okay okay put it in
oh my God I swear to god dude I
my heart is racing so what's the next
flavor what's what's on the label what
do you say about it this is uh the last
dab Carolina Reaper special edition
Reaper Edition
the last dab single pepper series
remixes this spiciest sauce on hot ones
replacing pepperax with some of the
other heavyweights of the chili World
Experience smoking Ed Curry's world
famous Carolina Reaper and then in its
blazing Glory
teams only by the zingy blend of mustard
Ginger and turmeric Chris is so worried
it's the most worried I've ever seen
Chris
go like this let's just do this
take a trip
foreign
was I supposed to shake this
you think anyone's ever accidentally
gotten this in their eye yes I know I
gotta be well it's Gotta Be law of the
adventures
okay
go ahead
hold it steady
I'm gonna put what I gave me okay okay
okay okay okay okay
yeah oh pimpy doing this with us
I'm not gonna be able to I'm not gonna
be able to let me put it on the chip for
you because I don't think I'm gonna be
able to
does your mouth is your mouth fine now
pimp
yeah put like that though
yeah see like that though
I don't feel good at all man I do feel
nauseous you feel nauseous too yeah yeah
that's a good amount I do I feel
something off with my head yeah my soul
throw up let's do it all right ready all
right let's do it go
foreign
this one is not hitting me like the
other one it might kick in a little
later I feel in it
this one is not hitting mine's speeding
up now it's getting there oh really it's
a slow Burn yeah mine's speeding the
[ __ ] up right now
oh my God I just choked it it burned
what do you guys think about this
article oh
122 year old woman said she smoked for
100 years and ate two pounds of
chocolate weekly I think that I'm this
122 year old woman
I have so much
saliva yeah this is not saliva is crazy
this is a slower burn
the other one burned immediately it's
like your head vibrates huh come on he
in a character that's bigger than the
Chihuahua that bug the thing is eating a
full-grown carrot the whole carrot is in
this bug's mouth like he's a human being
that's an ant
the bug is as big as a gerbil
and loves carrots I wonder if he loves
but if you saw a bug as big as a gerbil
I'll tell you right now one of two
things is happening one of three things
what is it if I don't have a bombshell
to live in okay oh God I hate bugs oh if
I don't have it bugs traffic sweat the
common cold strong wind bugs bugs is my
fifth most hated thing bugs uh if I came
into a bomb shelter and I cannot Escape
a bug like that
I'm drinking the poison myself that's
what I'm doing I'm drinking the poison
myself well so you don't think you can
win
so who would win in a fight then you or
a room full of ten thousand bucks
all the bugs win
100 ten thousand but what all sizes or
these big bugs just let's say let's say
you have ten the box is an assortment
it's a none of them flies it's like a
it's like a trail mix of bugs yeah but
it could be from the smallest to the
biggest
look at that
five inch giant water bug this is the 10
biggest bugs apparently okay this is a
giant water bug that's four and a half
inches
so a giant water bug at just as big as
homeless Pimp's penis
hey Siri
what is eight
eight times seventy
there you go so 500 if you could have
done that math 560 billion pounds no
times 70. that's eight times seven
that's eight billion times seven oh
that's 56 billion okay she's right so
serious right so the bugs weigh 560 no
I'm sorry the bugs weigh as much as
560 billion humans
so if a human is what's the average
human want to say 150 pounds that's what
I said yeah hey Siri
what is 506
billion times 150 is 8.4 times 10 to the
13th power
yo she doesn't even have a word for it
wow she had to spit back just that's how
heavy bugs are it's 84
with it's the number 84 with 12 zeros
after it is how how heavy the bugs are
if I did that right my God
that's as much Elon Musk that's he they
got Elon Musk weight yeah that's crazy
that's crazy wow here we go when Atlas
beetle also known as a chocolate colossa
is 5.1 inches you know you got to show
these this is insane we're gonna put it
up that thing's got a goddamn horns
what does it do all day it's got horns
is it Jewish
oh
yeah cut that part out I'm just kidding
I just want to do a dad joke
what Dad
mine mine yeah my dad's name is Adolf uh
yeah oh my Hercules oh every one of
these huge bugs is also just happened to
be absolutely terrifying disgusting I
mean a 6.7 inch Beetle this has to be
like in a rainforest somewhere right
this is why I don't go to the rainforest
yeah but back during dinosaurs weren't
the bugs supposed to be like oh my God
dinosaurs though
it seems like beetles are the biggest
bug could you just step on one of these
things with your shoes still I don't
know I feel like it would be like that's
you'd have to get a new shoe this thing
the largest insect on Earth go back up
to that name uh pimpy please uh
24.6 inches the largest insects on Earth
so it's two feet these guys holding in
his hands
looks like an asparagus it looks like it
looks like a tree branch with legs
oh God yo if I saw any one of those
things the largest insect that ever
lived was a mega mega neuroprocious
permeana it's a basically a it's
basically a dragonfly the size of a
Chihuahua yes it's a dragonfly bigger
than a Chihuahua yeah it's a flying
Chihuahua dragonfly I'm assuming that's
a mock-up of it yeah yeah yeah
what would you do if you were sleeping
one night and that was on you
no that's it I'm telling you right now I
don't know what I would do I don't know
what I would do could you rather deal
with that or a rat
because you deal with an insect or
around so you're saying one is going to
wake you up a long bug or a rash or a
rat one is gonna wake you up crawling
all over your body you're going to be
strapped down to a bed you have to deal
with it for five minutes which one is it
oh that's a tough call bro that's why
we're doing rats freak me out mice don't
rats do yeah rats people people breed
and have rats as pets and they don't
necessarily attack you
so I I don't know man I'm going to tell
you something disgusting right now when
I when I
was doing that gig with the bald eagle
by the way the bald eagle got paid more
than me rightfully so when I was doing
that gig the Handler by the way for all
you bald eagles out there just go to
keeps use the promo code hey babe that's
what it is so this is Elvira she's a
Craiglist find right oh that's good
that's on the up and up yeah
oh my God it's literally terrifying yeah
it is terrifying Bro Look at its black
no I didn't realize it was going to be
like my wife stick I'm sure you guys
okay whoa now this one's beautiful
mine's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen here okay actually they send
spear right
don't be a dick no but they did
but just stand up and put it put it in
front of Sal's face like it's a friend
of mine just quickly just stand up don't
give it to him but I just want you to
experience what I'm experiencing Sal how
terrifying it is just touch it
it's looking still looking at don't be
rocking money
I bet you've had subscriptions you
didn't know about for a long long time
love it rocket money formerly known as
true bill cancel them personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place you're giving me blue bills you
know people say use it or lose it this
is use it and and lose it which I like I
made that up and thank you listen new
year new me new year new goals are to
manage your budget better and save money
then guess what you need rocket money
because you know this is something this
solves a problem because all those
places they in the fine print they go
it'll keep renewing it'll keep renewing
until you're gone and then you will look
to cancel it you're like where do I who
do I sometimes they want a letter to
cancel something on the phone to cancel
it since it's 19.50 how about I light a
rocket and shoot it right at you yeah
I'll shoot it right over because over
three million people have used rocket
money saving the average person up to
720 20 a year and makes canceling easy
and a click of a button stop throwing
your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
hey babe that's rocketmoney.com hey babe
what is it rocketmoney.com hey babe I
want to get in your box your butcher box
which I got my delivery yesterday me too
14 pounds of organic Meats yummy I throw
it right in the freezer I'm set for the
winter now butcher box takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
Meat and seafood you can trust 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken pork raised crate free and wild
caught Seafood I love butcher box it's
fantastic it's the New Year too you have
resolutions you probably want to start
eating healthier right I mean all this
stuff is top quality okay it goes right
to your door you don't have to worry
about going to the market and carrying
home 14 pounds no he comes right to your
door also I'm always worried like I
don't know is this good is this not good
I don't know how if this is right good
with butcher box yeah I promise you it's
good they got recipe inspiration they
got a lot tips it's only so high quality
cuts that are sometimes hard to come by
at your local grocery which I love yes
get that sounded out there that's
they're cutting up the butcher right now
that's where butcher coming with the Box
get the New Year bundle for free plus
ten dollars off when you sign up today
that's a 14 ounce pork tenderloin two
pounds of ground turkey and four top
sirloin steaks free in your first box
all you got to do is go to
butcherbox.com hey babe use the code hey
babe to claim this offer ah we love
butcher box
if you don't want to touch it like that
that's like you know you don't want to
poke at it I'm sorry I'm actually scared
of snakes
I didn't beat up drug dealers when I was
16.
oh it doesn't feel bad oh it's beautiful
man I feel like lovers is that just one
muscle is that what that is this is one
muscle they have a spine and ribs why
does it smell like adobo
if you chop like oh actually this is if
you chop off like the back foot there
dice the tail does it die no I mean they
can anything before uh the anal vents
it'll probably survive okay yeah
no they don't generate they don't
regenerate their tails like certain
lizards do okay so if you're gonna chop
a snake get above the [ __ ] yeah if
you want to take it
they'll be moving for hours shout out
anal vents shout them all out yeah shout
them all out the anal vent um keep them
clean guys yeah
shout out cutesy names for asses yeah
yeah you know I found a new name the
anal vent and I'm gonna call my penis
the hemipeen yeah come on give me a chat
Chris just stand up tall for me but I
don't wanna it's a new shirt
he's very cool I will say this I will
say this I don't want to do it at all
if you do it I'll do it
this act as a tree but Sergio be here
yeah hold the mic for me well hold on a
second there
just what are the odds what are the odds
because there are odds that he just
takes a bite of our Goddamn face
50 50.
have you smelled Chris's breath it
smells like a dead rat
oh [ __ ] Chris I I lied I was lying I I
completely lied hey okay I'm okay you're
fine yeah but he's gonna when he starts
to wrap around you know he's not gonna
wrap around you you let me know when
you're done
what's up guys do you dance
I got hey what's up everybody got a
brand new hour go to christycomedy.com
for Tiki Wiki's second show added in
Dublin Belfast London sold out
um Chicago Theater sold out go check
christycomedy.com we're going to
announce New Year's Eve in Long Island
um all my dates at christiecomedy.com
it's a brand new hour of uh comedy
material
I love animals
oh my God my God he's fine he's fine
look he's fine he's that close
so a slow flick of the tongue it's just
curiosity test one a short fast one is
very like unsure of itself like what the
[ __ ] is going on is it food is you know
don't [ __ ] some [ __ ] up I'm good
thank you that's my fit
yeah there you go the youth serving
looks what are you talking about this I
don't serve looks anymore I just go for
complete Comfort I'm at a I thought it
was gonna grab my eyeball
so I also have I did it I have one more
Snake style you want to try this one
he's Brave girl Oliver Oliver's next
what's what's up Oliver is the next one
what is that Oliver is a Burmese python
the Everglades is an invasive species
what is it what is is it is it more
dangerous than that one none of them are
dangerous let's cut that talk out very
negative
none of my dangerous see he's cool
all right I'll try it I feel like my job
is not being done here I want to like I
want I want to be having like a snake
party I feel like you're traumatized
that promised me that I promise you that
you're gonna be fine you'll keep that
face away from us and I will I will I
want this to be and honestly we're
joking around but I want to be a
positive experience I don't want to
freak anybody already dude will it sense
my sweat no I'll be fine this one it
doesn't like the shampoo I use no it'd
be fine okay yeah he's very tolerant all
right all right so I'm just gonna put
them around your shoulders I'll hold the
head but I might it's good to do one
thing a day that scares you this is it I
know I'm just telling you right now my
heart is beating out of my chest is it
gonna feel that no it's going to take a
blood pressure meds today I can't go
near that face though okay okay I'll do
it outside take my blood pressure okay
uh can you hold this for me and put your
phone down how many milligrams are you
on
50.
um I I uh I don't know exactly okay
let's I'll talk we can I just got I just
got put on blood pressure medicine
this is not good let's talk about our
meds um just stay right right by me
Sergio just stay right by me yeah I'm
gonna be right by you
okay
the snake doesn't
sense of 10 out of 10 scared level okay
I'm scared just watch it I don't look it
in the face I'm scared it would be gold
off the biggest face I ain't gonna look
at the face I ain't gonna look at the
things all right
her face
go over here I'm saying right here
I thought oh okay it's just his ass I up
ahead
I got the head
I'm gonna be in Canada October 14th and
15th Hamilton Toronto we edit a show I'm
gonna be in Richmond Virginia and
Hershey Pennsylvania in October
in November I'm going to be in
Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham where
is the [ __ ] where is this
[ __ ] please no you're fine
you're fine I got it I'm very scared
dude
I'm going to be in Louisville and
Evansville and then in December I'm in
Florida and California and Florida I'm
in Tampa we had a second show show I'm
at the hall Hard Rock in Orlando the
Crest Theater in Sacramento uh
Jacksonville what's up on that
and see Sacramento San Jose and Santa
Rosa in December everything's on sale
right now on sale volcanocomedy.com
well done well done there you go
feeling like this
I got that I'm looping around though not
exactly no no
his head's looking right at me
wow there's a little is it [ __ ]
because the anal vent is a little dark
black what does its [ __ ] look like
cat [ __ ]
snakes she looks a little bit like Kasha
but that's also like calcified like
urates like the urine so it's like
liquid but it's also like a scientist or
something I don't know we got one more
what do you feel about snakeskin items
hate it I'm indifferent I don't get
offended by it what does that does that
mean the snake died for it or is it just
yeah it's a part of a trade just like
you might get a fur coat yeah yeah but
is that that's not from shed skin no no
that's actual skin okay and those are
usually much larger constrictors like
constrictors like reticulated pythons or
African rocks and they go find them to
hunt them to chops yeah you know it's
not wasteful you can eat the meat what
do you think about that have you ever
tasted snake no I had crackers I had an
alligator I believe a frog what do you
think about people eating snake I think
it's fine
let me ask you a question
it's it's the end of days I got the
eating habits of a badger I eat anything
it's the it's the end of the day vaginal
would you eat would you eat would you
would you resort to eating a human first
or a snake if they're both dead you got
a human and a snake what do you need an
animal too well I don't know what it
seems like you love snakes more than you
love your own family
I'm an athletic kid I was pretty thin
but in in a Jewish house if you're 10
pounds overweight you're enormous you're
fat so I went to fat camp and then I got
fatter every year you know if it's a
real thing yeah I went to Fat care
they're real singers I talk about it on
stage a lot now it's it's a camera
really yeah
he's like like so you lose weight is
that what it's for it's you you go no no
it's okay you go and you literally get
woken up at six in the morning and you
have to go walking for three miles in in
the Dead Heat in the middle of the
summer I went in the Berkshires with
mostly Jewish kids not all Jewish kids
but wait wait I was not even fat what is
it not kidding cloaked as you don't tell
your kids you're going it doesn't say it
doesn't say like fat camp on the on the
sign and spray paint when you go through
the fact it's like wellness camp but
it's his fat camp it's fat camp you go
it's everyone's like everybody was fat
well I was like the thinnest I was one
of the thinnest kids but it was some
kids are obese and would they what would
they do would they like just like
hundreds of kids I'm not kidding yeah I
went and they all knew that they were
there because they were overweight oh
yeah that doesn't empty something to the
psyche of course of course yeah it was
more rhetorical but yeah
I'll tell you all about it you you eat
very small meals very you you're
restricted and then you you you're not
going to believe that it's really crazy
you line up you would line up in your
bathing suit like on on the Hills to get
weighed every Saturday no and then you
would get away you would get weighed
where you ate talk about how sick that
is you got Wade in the mess hall where
you ate every day breakfast lunch and
dinner they would have scales like this
doesn't exist yes it does not in this
fact it does what's Fat Cam call now I
went to cam Kingsman see if it's still
open they weighed you in front of
everybody there's cam Shane that's the
biggest one they weighed you in front of
everyone yeah well you got way everyone
lined up to get weighed so people saw
you getting weighed
I swear to God this is true that's where
I went Kingsman
wow
now they call it the fifth Farm
they hire some PR these kids aren't even
overweight at all oh my God so I was not
very heavy I'm telling you I I blew up
every summer I got fatter and fatter
because of this yes
they're making it like as an active
Fitness Camp Fitness is different than
go you're going we're shipping you away
well we did do Sports all day but but
listen this is the thing every morning
and then you would go walking up and
down Hills next to cows in the pasture
oh my God they were like they were like
these are last year's campus sounds like
I'm being funny but you would like I
felt like we would hold on to the trunks
of the other [ __ ] of the other like you
know kids and you would just walk up and
then sweat like it was the dead of
Summer did you and you would Mar you
would like with all the other kids in
the camp walk up and down the hills and
like people would drive by and it was
mortifying yeah with all fat kids so
they were all they better be yeah and
they were all I felt like they were all
in like in programs in college you know
like
for you know stuff that you would have
done you know what I'm saying right
Physical Therapy oh yeah yeah yeah or
nutrition but I felt like every night
they probably went back to their their
bunks and like got high and drunk and
like made fun of it that's what they do
that's what they do in the movies they
were nice so like it wasn't like nobody
was like abusing you or anything like
that but wait but wait wait wait wait if
you if your parents had felt that you
were fit to their liking would you have
gone to camp
I went to camp for years but my parents
had a hard time with me
being heavy because they had a lot of
issues with their own looks you know I
came from that from the way you looked
from you know appearance was important
and they cared about me they didn't you
know it was a part A lot of it was they
didn't want me to make fun of us they
wanted me to you know that was a lot of
it it wasn't like they were they were
sending you to fat camp for them not you
well I think they were sending it to for
me too to help me in a partner but it
didn't help you it made it worse well
they it's not like they they did it to
be me I think they were doing it to help
me and a part of me wanted to go too you
know I was a teenager so I thought oh
let me go away for the summer well it
must have been it looked good and try to
get healthier and then I became friends
with people and I enjoyed it it wasn't
like a horrible experience I had fun
yeah and I was around nice people who
accepted me it's not like I wasn't
popular in school though right of course
I always had friends because I was funny
yeah I was gonna say you're hilarious
when I when you were not great it wasn't
good for me I'll tell you that much it
was not good because it got me heavier
and heavier and heavier how so because
because I didn't learn anything and then
I would lose all this weight quickly and
then go right back to school and gain it
right back plus more
because it's not healthy so you go back
to school in September and be like would
you do for somebody to do it I'd be like
oh my God it was a great time and they
were like no you didn't yeah
no wait when you were there at that age
though did you acknowledge it as fat
camp did you all the kids be like we're
at fat camp we know where we are yeah we
all knew we were in fact was there
anybody who wasn't fat at all like they
were noticeably skinny but they were in
fat camp because their parents thought
they were fat well that was me kind I
mean not you weren't fat compared to
them would they take a shredded kid at
least I was like not I was athletic like
I was always played Sports yeah I mean I
played tennis in high school and
Lacrosse and volleyball but I was like
10. we know you're a lesbian
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
I mean I was also molested in Fat Cam by
a counselor but that's the show yeah but
I think I asked for it because my
clothes were really tight so I think I
asked for it and what happened how they
molest you
um not they wasn't like a gang bang but
um no it was a it was a counselor I was
like 14 and and a counselor uh would hit
on me this guy Fred he was so perverted
but I didn't know what it took the time
[ __ ] friend you piece of [ __ ] spread
if you're watching right now we know
that you are look what you've done I
look like Fred identify Fred I want to
play Fred in the movie
I'll get you the part oh my God who's
gonna play you I don't know maybe Barney
um
wait would they accept a shredded kid
could you imagine
Jonah Hill's new world
14 year old I am
waiting Jonah Hill in the movie that
played the girl oh precious Gabbert days
could you imagine if that's who played
me I think that aging is just a part of
living yeah and we should just celebrate
getting old as [ __ ] so I recently not
recently but like the last couple years
I I got a line here because I squint so
much because I have bad eyesight and it
finally caught up to me and like became
a perm so it's like right here right it
wasn't there like a few years ago and
it's been annoying me
so you think you're gonna get talks no I
didn't think so but I had a friend of
ours and I won't say any names because I
don't know although they probably say
that they get talks all the time but
they were like just get talks and I was
like I'm a little nervous and they said
it's just some botch in the face and it
goes away I said but what about those
people that you see they get so much
that they like no longer addictive smile
and then he says yeah but that's not
what it is you just get a little bit
you'll never know so many people have
Botox and you don't even know it because
they do it the right way you just don't
want to get shot up all in your grill so
then I was like well they said it's not
it's safe and it goes away and it's not
a big deal and they started to make a
case for it because I've never even
entertained it for a split second
because in my head you're just shooting
botulism in your face and it's it's it's
but I know and then I found out after he
told me more people I knew that did that
do it that I didn't know and then I'm
like if it just takes out this little
line here and again never in my life
would I get elective search never
you wouldn't I wouldn't but I think like
I don't know it's like you go in you pay
like a few bucks they it takes like five
minutes and you leave that sounds like
that sounds like Fair
yeah I feel like you if you got addicted
to Botox I gotta be honest with you it
would be like even though it'd be like a
thing that we'd all deal with together
as your friends and family but secretly
we'd be laughing I mean a lot laughing
it would be because you with like the
Catwoman face would be really really
really like hard to take funny yeah but
I would not
but I wouldn't get it that bad but I'm
saying if you got an addiction if I got
addicted like everyone else is nothing
could stop you you're addicted to tick
tocks I'm addicted to Botox Botox can we
pull up the world the world the worst
box uh worst Botox woman
you know what it is it's just raging and
security what's raging in security yeah
I look like a guy in the back
[Laughter]
oh my God look at her face it's poor
thing poor little girl they shouldn't be
allowed to do that to her now it's
almost the doctor's fault right
she looks like a cartoon
all right what about no what about like
worst worst plastic surgery does that
woman Jocelyn Jocelyn Wildenstein
yeah put put worst plastic surgery wild
and steam oh my God
oh
the real dude it's just not good
I mean at what point oh no
oh no oh boy oh boy oh no
wait the one hold on the one laying in
the bed just a few back she was like I
done [ __ ] up yeah she was like she's
like I done went and I [ __ ] up yeah a
little bit more there you go she's like
please get out of my [ __ ] face I hate
my life but then if you fast forward
this other girl is out of a hospital and
she's got a parakeet on her shoulder and
she's like I've accepted this and this
looks good look at that woman's eye that
that cannot be real that can't be real
is that a filter yeah
let's go to number one
that's monkey pox
yeah number one is that woman that's her
this is her yeah Joyce Wildenstein she
looks like a full she looks like a like
a like a Sphynx cat yes she does she
looks like a cat wait I have a question
like is she like what does she do and is
she alive and well and she must know
that she she made a few wrong turns at
Albuquerque and she can't come back from
it but I'm not here to put her down so
much as to understand how and why how
and why is what we're trying to get to
the bottom of is a little how and why I
think it's Jocelyn
Wildenstein good luck spelling it uh
pimp spelled before he spelled uh
analogous
Joe was like I'm gonna I'm gonna give
you an analogous sense and I was like
okay I don't know if analogous is where
I know you mean analogy he goes no it is
he goes type it in a return and we
started cracking up we're like pimp can
take 200 times and not spell analogous
and he got it on the first try
something happened today with pimp put
letters together in a row that and
anything else just lucked out yeah
I mean yeah because but but that's
usually how it goes is people who can't
spell easy words can spell insanely hard
words yeah that's what it is well look
at her in the 70s you know you get where
she's coming from that's crazy because
because in 98 she was already like done
[ __ ] up and then five years later in
2003 she's like let me I would be like
all right let's pump the brakes is that
a real picture from 2008 because
honestly again I'm not here to shame but
if that person was walking the street
it's so unnatural it'd be genre here's
what happens is I'll be honest is is it
we're looking at these pictures right
now and pimp we could put them up in the
app is in 1970s she looks like an old
person then 1998 she looks out of
control nuts 2003 [ __ ] gets even worse
but then 2008 somehow she starts to look
more like she did in 1970s she almost
comes full circle with her plastic
surgery oh my Lord dude that is I want
to know if that's real that top left one
see that's what I'm talking about you
know on a lake and you can get a brain
eating amoeba yeah come on man with the
Lakes
stuff that can go like up your pee hole
oh yeah hell yeah dude because when I
was in we filmed an episode in New
Orleans and uh I was in the bayou and I
was so nervous about alligators but
about [ __ ] amoebas and [ __ ] and that
I I wore a condom through the whole
thing
yeah and then uh so that's a remote
control alligator and they they I didn't
know that that was they had that and I
literally had a did you see me run I
thought an alligator was coming at me
and when I ran to the boat Joe thought
that I was wearing a helmet and he took
that ore and he slapped me in the head
with it and there was nothing but my
soft Cranium underneath and he hit me
and my literally my eyes went to
blackout I almost went to blackout and I
almost fell back and underneath the
water oh my god dude I was like ah I was
like that [ __ ] hurt he goes I thought
you were wearing a helmet I go no he
goes oh my God I'm so sorry
here's what my prayers used to be I used
to say the Our Father the Hail Mary the
glory to be and then I would I would
always I don't know where I got taught
this I would always be asked I would
always silently ask for help I would say
to Jesus I would say please let there be
peace on Earth I would say please let
there be peace on Earth please let me
make the NBA and I would always end it
with please let my parents lose the
weight they need to lose to be healthy
again no you didn't I swear
Our Father who aren't in heaven okay
well he's in heaven who are
I'll never think about like how God the
all-knowing like you know he knows the
hour of your death he's like this
[ __ ] don't even know he don't
even know he look at him out there he
don't even know he got an hour silly he
got an hour he's out there being goofy
he's out there being goofy he's on he's
an out he's on IG live my man got an
hour
he doesn't even understand boom bap he's
done you don't even know you got it and
I can't even reverse it get it reverse
it let me work it yeah put my thing down
flip it in reverse
excuse me I noticed that you were doing
81 and a 65. would you like to explain
yourself
um good morning officer I um it's it's
one o'clock good afternoon
sir are you is something wrong are you
on a substance of some of some sort no
no I I'm just a little nervous because I
don't know why I've been pulled over you
don't know why you've been pulled over
do you want to take a guess I mean I
think maybe I was going a little bit
faster a little bit faster than the
speed limit you were going 16 miles an
hour faster
in relation to 65 miles an hour as the
speed limit you were going about 25 too
fast
I totally understand my major the math
was there an emergency
I do have to get back home to Staten
Island um I haven't been with my uh kids
uh for a few days and um I do I just
would like to get say no more get out of
here
what's this on your front seat
that's um
smells like [ __ ]
I get so Sneezy in the middle of the
night tissues aren't enough I take off
my shorts and blow my nose into my
shorts
I have no choice but to do that
[Music]
who are you gonna who puts up with this
I I'm I've never heard of this in my
life I'm told I've been told many many
many many many many times you don't want
to get out of bed okay guys I've been
told many many times by Jasmine my
girlfriend my mother my children she's
like if women knew
how disgusting you were yeah and and
what it really was like living with you
none of these girls would ever put heart
eyes on your Instagram pics none of
these girls would ever tell you that
you're cute because she said you are by
far the most disgusting human being yeah
I've ever been around in my life and I'm
like why don't you leave then she's like
because you Q
yo that is disgusting dude yeah like I
just a little bit my opinion changed of
you just now so we go to land right we
go to land we're on this little plane
and it's bad out but he was like talking
to us sternly and he goes okay so we
have a small issue
one of the wheels is not coming down
Loop back around for the fourth time for
the third time we went to go land I was
full I'm not ashamed to say it I was
full crying were the other guys crying
um Q was trying to hold it together for
me Murray was visibly shaken and then
Joe The Lunatic that he is he he just
had a shirt singing La Bamba you know
they all died in a crash
how long were you thinking you were
gonna die at all uh it was a matter of
like five ten minutes and as you were
Landing this has happened to me before
did you see a bunch of fire trucks I was
just about to say loaded the runway and
then and then we touched down and the
wheel was down so it was it was a normal
Landing yeah normal yeah yeah so did
they still take you in a Stretcher
they're like this woman well the guy
I know I saw a rainbow in Ireland uh
there's no way I could have known that
but
it was do they do they do they have
better rainbows than us probably without
it I mean that's that's it that's the
home of the rainbow that's the whole
thing a lot of gold yeah so and then I
pulled over and and the picture of the
the the rainbow wouldn't come out on the
photo as only as it was almost like it
was if to say you can only view this it
was a vampire rainbow it was dude I ate
a scone I ate a rest stop scone in
Ireland best scone I've ever had in my
life how old are these scones she goes
to uh we just made them fresh and I said
what do you mean you just made them
fresh she goes we make them right here
we pop them in the oven and we made them
fresh
and I was like I'm gonna know right now
give me a death scone and I was messing
with her I said if it's not fresh I
don't pay for it she said you have a
deal
I swear to God Valencia is Balenciaga
wow they're selling two thousand dollar
trash bags enough enough enough
disrespectful Balenciaga 1 790 uh trash
bag now is it a fashion trash bag or do
they want you to put like is it a bag
it's supposed to be a bag God if that's
just made like a trash bag Yeah ironic I
guess yeah interesting and kids are
buying this off the shelves yeah I've
been doing that for years it's called
Hefty okay yeah and it's got a little
scent in it so my clothes don't stick
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah does Balenciaga
have a cinch sack yeah
I've done that many times this is
the fashion out of homeless people's
luggage essentially Zoolander Dara
leaked right right it is just oh it's so
insulting in the way like you ever have
a real fat day and then you put on loose
clothings and you feel skinny mini
immediately yeah what's up like I feel
thin immediately let's eat yeah no if
this is what being lizzo feels like I
love it I sign me up yeah really spread
it yeah you're getting great oh you're
great you did great you think I'm good
at this I feel like you've this isn't
the first time you've applied Mass tell
you that much first time I've ever
applied a physical mask I have applied
masks emotionally yeah but physically
first time I've ever done this you
really are thorough uh and efficient
thank you when are you going to New
Zealand first two weeks of December you
want to come
[Laughter]
thank you
you look you look very
you look like you need a chaperone
LSD the drug LSD was created through
um
code name of an illegal human
experimentation program designed and
undertaken by the U.S the CIA are you
serious yeah it's real MK Ultra is a
real thing and they and they developed
procedures and identified drugs such as
LSD that could be used in interrogations
to weaken individuals and force
confessions that is in yeah they a lot
of people think the conspiracies that
Charles Manson was under the influence
of MK Ultra and that's why what happened
happened and he's like the CIA scapegoat
oh you gotta be kidding me I I here's
what I gather there's a lot we don't
know probably foreign
[Laughter]
I would invest in the metaverse and of
course you know I'm Chrissy crypto but
the board ape thing just seems like a
scam does it not pimpy that's it right
there that's the price of the house you
bought yes 1.29 million yes you know
what I'm saying so you could shelter
your family
indefinitely indefinitely well you could
have that cartoon ape on a digital file
well I'm gonna have to break the news to
my kids tonight what does that mean an
nft restaurant opening in New York will
serve up status with a side of seafood
what does that mean though yeah so like
but my question is the nft like is it is
it an edible nft or you're saying
regular membership token on the second
so you pretty much buy like whatever the
like uh the board ape thing and it acts
as a ticket to the Social Club but can I
only use it once no no you're a member
if you have so if you own an nft you can
go in yeah but you could buy an Etsy for
five dollars okay no it has to be their
nft they minted that's a like hey oh
okay oh see to access the club members
must have a fly fish nft which is a
unique digital asset stored on the
blockchain and purchased using
cryptocurrency the company released
1501 tokens this month bringing in
around 15 million dollars
so they're now saying
that you buy a token to even enter the
restaurant and they made 15 million
dollars before selling a piece of food
oh glitch in The Matrix go to 114 glitch
in The Matrix this is like real what
look
watch
it's just Frozen that can't be real no
it's real that had to be that had to be
someone edited that and put it up online
no this happened like live on the air
people were like tweeting like what
happened to Shaq did he have a stroke
like it was a whole thing
and then he just comes out of it I
remember seeing this yeah yeah nobody's
even noticing
what how Wild is this yeah
that looks like it's Frozen no that
looks like it's frozen that'll look real
looks like Paul's television
really one other thing too I just want
to mention quickly about going through
this Wormhole is that they think also
another real likely likely thing that's
gonna happen is a lot of people will go
to Mars like that's gonna just be a
thing no but in inhabit habitate Mars
and then what's going to be interesting
is when but but they'll come back it's
not like they'll just want to put humans
to live there whatever time share oh
yeah exactly sure
but over like the course of like 100
years because there's like 30 or 40
percent less gravity on Mars people are
going to become a lot taller No taller
because there's less pressure in their
spine so their spine expands so the
average human the average male in we're
shorter because gravity's pulling us
down yes the average no they're going to
be taller and weaker though too a little
weaker but the average male in 1800 was
five seven they were saying if we lived
on Mars for 100 years the average male
by like
2100 would be six seven wow so that's
why so that and that's why like when a
lot of people think they see aliens they
see very tall beings because there's no
gravity they think it's a gravitational
thing gravity makes you talk so they
have people why are we taller now though
is there less gravity huh why are we
taller than the average nutrition
nutrition okay but but they they have
actually people NASA has people now that
Lit there's people out there now that
are living for science living in like
zero gravity places to see what it does
to their body they just volunteer to be
like I'll do it well they want to do it
yeah they want to give back to science
that's a lot I would do it that's asking
a lot they my guess they don't got a lot
going on yeah you know what I mean
shit's not going good they dropped out
of Community College maybe dishonorably
discharged from the military they set
them up with a [ __ ] PS5 yeah all the
seamless they want if I could have
Buffalo Wild Wings if my career was
failing and you tell me I get as much
PlayStation Buffalo Wild Wings and maybe
they maybe a a prostitute every month
right you would do it you're dedicating
your entire body to science that's it
you become although you know it would be
annoying they'd probably want you to be
healthy there's no chance is zero
gravity because like what's the point I
get to be fat as [ __ ] and like float
around yeah
[Laughter]
my tits would be just up at all times
yeah what's the point of living with
your gravity affects many parts of your
body as you age or compresses the spine
contributes to poor blood circulation
and decrease your flexibility that's why
I'm [ __ ] I'm grabbing I got aches and
pains yeah dude I've been living in too
much gravity that's right
um but uh do you ever do a zero graph
what is zero gravity like a like a like
sleep dep like a one of those no not the
chambers no well that I mean that that
kind of fear looks like if you ever go
into those chambers what and you just
float yeah man it's wild is it a is it a
therapeutic thing it's just for fun I
don't know but I know Fatone did it and
he just like literally floated around
the room that's sick like not one of
those things where like the air blows
you up like he went into zero graph
that's got to be only [ __ ] NASA has
access I think so we got invited to NASA
I wonder if they would have let us do it
absolutely where's NASA is it in Houston
right Houston we have a problem right
yeah I think it's Houston yeah shout out
Tom Hanks hola Fresca hello fresh hello
do you guys know what hellofresh is
Hello fresh yes I love hella fresh I do
too with hello fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes deliver right to your doorstep
uh skip the trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable it's
America's number one meal kit and that's
why and I'll tell you what else it's not
just meals anymore no okay it's
basically an online grocer and you can
get sweets and treats and Staples and
you throw them in your pack in your uh
in your cart and everything come with
the meals now yeah skip the snow skip
the snow he slept to the grocery store
and stock up on snacks sides desserts
and more at hello Fresh Market that's
what I love hello Fresh Market and they
got home gate treat the treat it like a
pro baby for the you know while football
season's going on sure yeah limit in
time only we got the winning assortment
of snacks apps and charitable sweets
right at hellofresh Market with
hellofresh eating well in the New Year
can be stress-free and delicious because
35 weekly recipes they have options
you're looking for to help you achieve
your goals choose calorie smart or carb
smart recipes even customize and select
your Meals by swapping proteins besides
upgrading and all that good stuff all
you got to do is go to hellofresh.com
hey babe21 use the code hey babe21 21
free meals
best deal in the biz free meals plus
free shipping plus free shipping
hellofresh.com hey babe21 use the code
hey babe 21 21 free meals plus free
shipping got one yesterday right I got
one yesterday that's why it's America's
number one meal kit you're gonna
love you guys this is real this is real
I don't believe it's real I'm telling
you this is real why how do you know
because a friend of mine okay sent me
this her two friends by the way a friend
of yours is a friend of ourselves
okay okay these are two people that she
knows and they were in their apartment
doing this this is what happened they
moved out the next day okay this is
confirmed what state what state where is
this Houston do we know
unfortunately that I do not know you
don't know the state I could find
something apartment I'm gonna tell you
that they're in New Jersey okay
Christmas lights could be Oklahoma City
it's only 10 seconds it's just four
seconds let's go they notice this after
the facts confirm you know these people
I know the
perk okay and if the person I said sent
me this I known 20 years and she's one
of my closest friends watch closely okay
yeah no problem they didn't they didn't
this is after the fact they saw this
they when they looked back at the video
they saw this I'm just wondering if she
has a pineapple in front of her door
they're playing that game with them
I sound like a smoker really I missed it
what was that around watch it again tell
me what it was around her hand right she
did playing that game when you dropped a
ring on the hook but yeah
oh the person walking by they don't that
they're only two of them in there they
don't live with anybody else no one else
is in the house let me let me break it
down again pause it go a little bit more
they don't that's in that whatever
whatever that is they don't live with
anyone nobody else was there and they
don't live with anyone I moved out the
next day
yeah man you got to say prayers right
after that bro you can't mess around
what was the prayer can we say it out
loud I say uh yeah
regime is like um
[Music]
nothing to do with Optimus look at this
Arab Christians too I'm sorry and they
all say say Allah Allah is just to work
I wash my feet every day yeah that's
very important though seriously people
that's why I learned it wrong
no I'm just basically like you know
asking for protection from God and then
you're you're basically anything evil
that comes from the devil if you believe
in that obviously and you know there's
well babe because you the whole thing is
you don't know if it's good or bad right
and you don't have to move out they
don't have to move out I've had
experiences where I've been in my house
um and all of a sudden I hear like knock
like over time like over a week I heard
like knocking like teasing then I heard
that it was the first front door like
click clap opening and then I heard the
door closed and I thought it was my
stepdaughter's you know before I got
divorced and I was looking around I was
like yo what was that I was like Elise
are you there like just nothing door and
then it's like laughing and then more
knocking bro I shut the whole place down
just turned on there's a particular you
know recommendation that my teacher
tells me you just play this particular
suit up this pretty good chapter her I
had a blasting all throughout and you
hit every corner in the house it was
gone
gone never never wait a second wait a
second so you're saying if you had a
like let's say you live in a let's say
you live doesn't matter where you live
you get an apartment but I'm just saying
well if you had a three-floor house
right and there were apparitions going
around like that
house alone like at night like just and
because you because a ghost you don't
care about a ghost you're like then I
don't like that wouldn't scare you
because if you're more scared of like a
real person I've been elected in in 30
minutes after this hilarious I would
immediately start doing what I was told
like to do what happens before like you
have to read a particular chapter it's
worked it absolutely works and you have
to do it in every corner like literally
every corner of the house I had a
blasting through the speaker like we're
on repeat and then I was going through
every corner and it was gone call your
friend I have no problem doing it get
them back in there get get the Quran get
them back in there have them start
reading the prayers this thing is out of
here it'll be gone
this is wild it gives me it gives me
chills bro this is so I got a full
apparitions the whole body's filled with
chills bro dude when I saw that
seriously the same thing right now I got
goosebumps
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe shouldn't have probably put up
their video of them you know on a
national Forum but like I couldn't I
could not believe this
this is yes yes the next here's the
thing if you don't deal with it they can
actually follow you you know so it's
like it's about it's about like taking
care of it so that ghost could just go
with them to the next house they can go
wherever they want this the whole thing
is they catch on to you they could yeah
they could well you're not only supposed
to see a psychic that attaches to you
too
[ __ ] these psychics bro all of them is
tarot cards all that [ __ ] you don't know
the whole point is I hate these [ __ ]
Ghost Hunter shows and all these things
I can't [ __ ] stand it it's called The
Unseen for a reason you don't know what
it is these [ __ ] are walking in like
there's a nine-year-old daughter this
girl is stuck here and come on out
Denise come on out it's okay say
something scrap [ __ ] you don't know if
it's a demon disguised as a
nine-year-old girl bro shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up I never thought about
that
show demon in Disguise that's the name
it's called a 90 it's called the Unseen
for a reason we ever think about your uh
your your awake and what who'll be there
and what will be said
yeah I always think like like when I
like if I died I wish I could see it
like what I would like would I make the
New York Post you know what I mean would
they write an article right would they
say ah you know can me or would you be
like yeah you know right like what do
you think you'd be big news oh you'd be
huge news
I think anyone like that's in the public
that dies will probably register
somewhere no but I mean you'd be like a
big like it'd be a big day you think so
if you went I think so right yeah New
York yeah yeah you think like another
place they wouldn't care really like
would they care in Sri Lanka that go
wild are they gonna be in Sri Lanka
maybe Sri Lanka yeah yeah a couple a
couple a couple of days on Twitter
trending and that's about it that's it
no but Hey listen but what happens at
the services though who shows up who
comes out of the woodwork who speaks
what do they say about you what do you
look like how you dressed what I would
do well I'd love to see what DeRosa
would post yeah
I want to get I would want to get buried
in a baseball uniform really dress me up
like the New York Yankees Pinstripes the
gold one like a Babe Ruth yep like this
yeah yeah what about you what would you
want to go in sweatshirts
yeah I'd say hoodie I mean throw me in
there in pajamas man yeah I'm resting
yeah right
putting a nice flannel two-piece
pocket on the front you want that do you
want to get better with anything a phone
or something laptop yeah probably one of
the one is a figurine or something throw
me in there with the phone call for bid
and then uh I don't know maybe some
photos I want to get buried with like a
you know a nice Pizza Pie that's nice
put it in there yeah you know give me
something right I have an aunt who she
tells I think I might have said this on
podcast before she like will bring it up
like at least once a year say hey
remember when I die take my shoes off if
you if you bury me with my shoes on in
the coffin I want you like that like out
of nowhere she'll be cutting like what's
the deal why does she think that she's
she's always had uh pain in her feet you
know she's always had messed up feet so
she said she tasked me with this when I
was about 10 years old that I must
remember to take her shoes off are you
gonna do it for real if I'm if I die
first yeah uh if I die second yeah she
dies first you're really gonna do it I
will not forget to do that it's been
ingrained in my head but did she let
anyone else in the family know because
then you're gonna look at psychopath
taking her shoes off yeah and everyone's
gonna be like leave her alone she needed
this it's my it's it's crazy it's a
little thing okay do you guys have any
requests for yours
um
I think I want a party man yeah just
yeah can I sell ads celebrate
I swear to God you own the documentary
rights at the funeral you open up the
casket it's just manscape I'm gonna
force them
Force the priest to do hello fresh
this guy Jesus Diaz Beto he got buried
sitting up like in his like he's dead
yeah that's his funeral he that person
is dead
in that photo he's dead he wanted this
on purpose this is a list of people who
are dead outside the coffin at their own
feet the 13 strangest funerals where the
corpses attended their own ceremony not
in a coffin and he sat he sat up with
this no yep yeah he's dead oh my God
yeah this old black woman is she has a
she has a cigarette in her dead hands
yes and she's holding a glass she's
drinking a bush beer in a in a wine
glass yeah may may Burbank who died of
cancer in early June 2014 pictured
seated at the table at the Chardonnay
Funeral Home in New Orleans wow she
looks like she looks like like a wax
what do you call it Madame two shows
this is the way to do it we'll bring the
couch and the signage
that if we die together we could just
have if we die together we'll just sit
on the couch just in the middle of a
pond
all right who go who's next
there you go oh man final Batiste oh
he's dead too in New Orleans it's at the
same Funeral Home Shopping hey
do not want people looking down at him
Wow Let's see Mickey easterling another
New Orleans
what is she doing
what's going on in New Orleans I don't
know they believe in all that stuff
like that spiritual Voodoo stuff
interesting
Billy Stanley no picture Willie Stokes
is hilarious
oh my God healed on the steps of a motel
no problem
they made the coffin they made the
coffin into a Cadillac they cut off the
back piece so he could sit up in it like
a car they put on a steering wheel which
by the way they could have done a better
job with that steering wheel yeah and
then they put wheels on the bottom of it
this is a dead man driving a Cadillac
Coffin yes
How does it go in the ground
dude I don't know his own mini Cadillac
Seville
oh my God
oh [ __ ] David Morales is being he's
buried on the motorcycle doing what he
loves best he's involved in balms
sitting on his beloved motorcycle but
he's in the racing position yeah he is
crouched down revving and his head is
that actually looks real yeah that looks
like how do they get him to stay like
that they must have him glued super
glued to the seat I don't know is that
not weird though oh my God oh my God
paramedic wait what's his name paramedic
and Edgardo Velazquez bombed in his
ambulance uniform in the ambulance he's
sitting in the ambulance let me ask you
a question go scroll up to the guy with
the thing is that for life is he
embalmed for life so he's gonna be like
basically like a piece of um uh like
when you have a Moose's head on the wall
what's it called Taxidermy yeah he's
basically like a piece of taxider I mean
like like if that was my loved one like
like his aunt or his wife or whatever
she props them up in the living room and
then he just stays there in that form
forever well no I think they'd probably
bury him oh you do because once you
embalm someone
embalming cannot completely halt the
natural process of decomposition in fact
it's against federal law to suggest an
Obama can completely stop decomposition
so you're committing crime if you even
suggest it embalming is one method
Funeral Directors have to ensure that
human remains are able to be interacted
with by the public you know
um I think maybe uh embalming could
prevent decomposition maybe well I mean
did I just I was going to say do you
mean say it again and I'll call the
police you're gonna make a citizen's
arrest now I'll make a citizen's arrest
right now like I just don't understand
like add to like a couple of oh so they
they don't stay long
no I think just for the funeral
but then you're gonna buy that
motorcycle put him on the motorcycle
just for a couple hours oh I think well
I think maybe it was his motorcycle okay
I mean yeah this guy is dressed in full
boxing gear yeah Christopher Rivera
Amora standing in the ring gloves on and
headband Amore could have been preparing
for the fight of his life if he wasn't
dead oh Jesus
no are you following
um
uh uh Ukraine like are you like kind of
interested yeah I'm I'm uh I'm I'm
interested I'm interested in I guess
now I am and I'm not what I'm what
because I don't believe I don't I just
don't believe what uh we're being told
is the truth I don't think that Ukraine
is winning like the news says their way
I kind of don't either but then they
then then Russia leaves Kirsten in these
cities and I'm like oh maybe maybe I
think that I do think that yeah in in
it's it's a complicated thing I think
for America to understand because like
Ukraine like you know like Kiev is like
that's like part of like Russian like
Foundation like this this is It's like a
sacred thing that they are together to
some of them to some of them right like
one of them Putin putty very old pootie
yeah they really are although what's his
name uh uh zielinski got a new jacket
huh yeah so let's get him real is that a
North Face like not dead I mean we
should be celebrating every I mean this
guy everybody thought he was going to be
murdered immediately and I gotta say put
on some weight though he did that's
interesting right in a war where you're
supposedly being the most sought after
guy or you're getting fatter he gets
diabetes he's still eating his feelings
um what's on your mind this is a cry for
help go ahead I mean I just yeah the the
the the the Russia Ukraine stuff I've
stopped I I don't really watch I don't
pay attention not that I don't pay
attention I think I have a you know we
have an obligation as Comics to pay
attention a little bit but I don't try
not to get sucked into it I remember
seeing the kid get dropped off at school
and we were probably like five or six
and his mom goes on his mouth and I was
like I mean I want to bang your mom but
that's [ __ ] weird yeah yeah like
that's it's it's it's like I I don't
know I kissed
well that Embrace is weird
oh Tom Brady just Tom Brady kids are too
many people that's funny that that
picture down there
who's the old man
it's his dad
um that's killing Edelman I I never kiss
you on the lips funny I would kill for I
would you know what I would like to get
kissed on the list by Tom Brady me too
I think parents and younger kids is out
of line I don't think I think I I I
think
I kiss my baby on the lips
I mean that's ridiculous whoa that's
that's got to be photoshopped that's
photoshopped that's got to be
photoshopped that's that's they're
they're literally locked
he's smushing his face
that can't be real I heard I heard Tom
Brady makes out with his son to Chubby
Clementine the song have you heard that
it's crazy that's weird yeah I mean I
kissed my dog I kissed my older daughter
on the lips sometimes it depends usually
it's on the cheek I just give her a hug
repeat you were like no no no no no no
not at all not in your family at all
Oh no just on like when you were a baby
[Laughter]
does the video get paused or is he there
that long
why that looked like it was the
beginning of CPL
any tea bags them
this is this video they're they're
actually talking about the kiss in the
video is that why this is a video to
begin with
it's funny that he's shirtless of being
massaged when it happens it doesn't it
doesn't help the agency it doesn't help
at the time yeah also it's weird this is
why I came back to the NFL just I was
like you never kiss him on the mouth
anymore
[Laughter]
hey Sean I love that he's showing it to
three black guys they're like these he's
like that's why people should
he goes it's two those two black guys in
DeNiro look at that guy was part of the
Kremlin I think you know but it's not in
the mouth but not for that long too long
too long like romantic long
I I was scrolling Instagram and I came
across an ad for a place that I've gone
to it's about it's called Bodega it's a
streetwear store and sneaker store in
Boston not Boston yeah right and um I've
I've patronized them and uh I saw some
things I went to their website and I
bought a couple things and I got mailed
here and one of the things I bought was
a hat
and I got the hat and it's like a 50 hat
and I tried it on and there is no way a
human being can wear this hat okay I
haven't I have it I'm gonna show it to
you you mean to tell I said okay I'm
gonna initiate a return
and I went on to Instagram I initiated a
return they gave me a ticket number and
everything and I tried to return it and
they never ever responded to me again
you tell me
okay YouTube
how is this supposed to be a hat with
somebody
[Music]
what head was this cut for that you're
selling this and then you're going radio
silent on the return request
whose head does this fit even if you're
saying this is the new style younger
kids are wearing it like this it's not
supposed to be a shallow hat you wear it
to the back maybe okay fine who is
wearing this hat okay but you put it on
were you like did you try everything
swear to God
and I go there's no way for me to even
do
I swear to God
oh my God
45
40 bucks in shipping and then I I
initiated I went on I said I bought this
I want to return it they said look for
an email to Bodega and it never came and
they won't pick up the phone nothing try
that
[Laughter]
you look like your special needs I mean
nothing no offense but you almost look
like you don't really care if it fits or
not but do you think that
you look like you're in the movie The
Ringer
it was ice cream
[Applause]
this is the whole interview though
[Applause]
wait wait wait wait what you said you
was gonna straighten me out what the
hell was that I said smooth you out okay
what does that mean you're not gonna
have a nice conversation
oh no I know how to chill okay but I
will not be disrespected
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god dude you should win an Emmy
for your appearance no Kenny has the
camera right here this is the up close
camera would you like it to be seen the
book comes out in October
what did I just do oh my God
I don't have one now right here listen
we're gonna start this over please help
me welcome my guest Omarosa
so
from the clip which I was one of the
reasons excuse me you were the reason
that I watched Celebrity Apprentice and
the reason being is that you are a
person who did Wendy Williams like was
that a professional movie
let me save this clearly Trump sees
something like that from you which is
why he invites you back over and over I
understand that there could possibly be
a show that you all will be working on
together possibly but I did the
Celebrity Apprentice because it was
about charity and I work with kids in
Compton who don't have an opportunity to
have a voice to fight for themselves
they face crime they face violence and
they don't have people to look up to so
I went on that show to tell people about
positive vibrations my charity in
Compton California okay well that was
that wow it's weird they like kind of
are doing a good job yeah because you
think you know that's bubbling under the
surface right now did she flip out at
some point Wendy Williams when she
passed out on the show who did you ever
seen one doing his pet can you play
himself
on this is wild nuts dude that's Wendy
Williams why is she who is she what is
she doing
broadcaster giant DJ oh yeah
but of course this is her on her show
like just but she was just a DJ that's
what she was and she was like a
celebrity correspondent yeah yeah I'm
allowed to say that but she was she's
that big right
costume contest we do it every year it's
always a lot of fun let's get started
our first caress
you know you never saw that before
and then he comes back dude can I tell
you something every Wendy Williams rerun
is wild like it is truly still the most
compelling show she's okay so we can
laugh right yeah because that's insane
no one was more entertaining than her
when she was trying and when she was can
you go back to that
what did happen what happened she had
like a blood you know whatever later
stroke
um it's not Grace Graves disease it's
something like that is she back doing
her show now she won't come back
you're in the crowd and have you spoken
to her or not I haven't no but I feel
weirdly
um like I dodged a bullet with her um
because uh uh sorry I just went like not
because I was supposed to work with
alcohol when
um
I I did have a show with him a couple
years ago I was like dodged a bullet
oops
um but uh no she uh Sherry Shepard was
also a guest host yeah the week before
me and the week after me and someone was
like oh should Sherry Shepard like
replace you if you don't come back and
she goes I don't know I would not watch
her post to my show like I didn't watch
any of the episodes yeah like she was
like throwing shade of people guest
hosting first he didn't like Michael
Rapaport then host a week like yeah she
had random people are similar you know
the [ __ ] she just throws out is so great
like also I wasn't allowed to say when I
was on the show because when she would
talk about the Britney Spears thing she
would go like death to them all death to
all of them that was her quote about
like all the conservators that were like
holding Britney Spears captains oh yeah
she would like call to like if you see
them in public like kill them like she's
just like but she's fearless in a way
that like no one on television is shout
out one to Williams shout out Wendy
Williams you're watching and we know
that you are she I gotta say though
imagine her in the audience and she goes
into that into that thing like because
the look of horror she had a look she
wasn't like confused or like I'm gonna
pass out she had a look of horror in her
eyes and it almost looks good and then
she just dropped straight down yeah it
seemed like she got it got control of it
yeah and then but but it looks it looks
like an SNL sketch it looks like an SNL
sketch I swear to God I can't she comes
and I think about what happened I think
she no no no no no look if you're in the
I think she comes on after the
commercial breakdown is like
legitimately fine the fact
s
of the Statue of Liberty collapsing too
it's funny she's just overheated in her
car she drops straight down
and I'm back I love that when she fell
they probably went right to like a my
pillow commercial yeah
first of all
that it's cool
in a light garment yeah you're like oh
and an air well air-conditioned studio
in Midtown what's Wild is that that
looks so scary and they they just shoved
it back out into the commercial right
away and chalked it up to it was just
from the heat from the outfit like how
do they know she didn't get a CAT scan
but if she came in with like the Statue
of Liberty Crown tilted
it's insane that she drops straight down
instead of forward
passed up the flight was in like three
hours so like I got there just you know
internationally you have to get like
check in two hours before like I was at
the last moments and I got in and I went
to Edinburgh I did not book my hotel in
Edinburgh Scotland until I was in the
middle of the Atlantic Ocean got well I
find the plane and then booked the hotel
and I had the best time ever is that
they call that flying by the city of
pants I think that literally what I was
doing I was flying by the seat in my
pants and I went there with just
underwear socks and one pair of pants
and one sweatshirt because I was like
what was the strategy there because I'm
like because what I like now with
traveling it's like I gotta bring 100
pairs of shoes it's all stressed but now
you land and you have to spend valuable
uh Scotland time going to buy underwear
no I had underwear and socks I as long
as I have underwear and socks I said
what how dirty are someone's pants
Really Gonna Get Right how dirty is your
sweatshirt really going to get that's
another tip my mom would always say is
travel light Pack Light always travel
light if you traveling with just a book
bag the amount of stress it drops is is
insane I don't get on the plane I don't
care about your space I don't care about
your overhead space yeah I got a
carry-on that's all I got I don't care
about it I gotta put back yeah I don't
need to I don't need the overhead space
take it put your [ __ ] kid up there
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] that's unbelievable
that is a long flight to book though for
just you have to be home by when Monday
I'd be home by Monday but when you're
coming back from Europe I left Monday at
12 I got home Monday at like 3 P.M
because you get six hours back and was
it a good trip are you kidding me the
best trip I had a great as a matter of
fact I because I knew my kids mom would
be mad at me I did a FaceTime with my
daughter from my hotel room she thought
I was home I was in Edinboro Scotland
like Harry Potter running around like
[ __ ] Harry Potter wow you ever do
anything like that no he's a [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] though
you call me a [ __ ] look I just got a
skin tag removed from my ass who didn't
see that cut the dermatologist
wow it hurts though
they uh lasered it off I thought that
electric thing yeah I thought I had
genital I thought I had a genital wart
on my ass but it's a skin tag isn't it
is it a genital warts
he's got them all over on the genitals
no but genital warts spread here's a
phenomenon with genital warts this is a
phenomena when or was it a phenomenon or
phenomenon phenomenon
so a phenomenon about genital warts is
you can get them on yourself one word
shout out phenomenons phenomenons you
can get them on your PP but then they
can come out on your butt but doesn't
mean you got anything on your butt but
they could just pop out of somebody else
was near your butt
don't try to pretend like you don't know
how you got them back there wait if
someone has them on their PP and they
touch something they transfer from the
pp to the other thing yeah
that's how those work yeah how do they
get them in the first place you know
genital warts I I don't know h p B
that's it that's the cause human
papilloma virus we all have it we all do
have it I think a lot of people have it
if you don't have HPV you ain't really
[ __ ] right right if you don't have
HPV you're just not someone I want to
know yeah like give me HPV yeah you know
me give me HPV yeah you know me who
[ __ ] tonight who [ __ ] at night you
got a hundred dollar bill with your
hands up you got a fifty dollar bill
all the god of sales be quiet
yeah
all right so you so you have to go down
you do what you do did you pull just the
cheek out of you that would actually
probably be like one of your worst
punishments then on the Jokers if some
if you your punishment was they have you
have to book a trip right now and go I
think you're gonna say get genital warts
you will you will you will you will on
the trip because that that's because I
think you're a very calculated you want
a plan which is great but I think if you
tried just try to do a trip not playing
see what happens just accept we tried uh
for years and they kept denying us doing
it we might try it again but we we
pitched for years a punishment called a
bus to Tampa we were going to take one
of the guys and sit on a bus with them
like and then just quickly hand cuff
them to the seat and then just get off
and that bus was going all the way to
Tampa and they just had to literally sit
on the bus we had the bus like we're
gonna have it camed up and they just sat
on the bus for the entire ride to Tampa
and what about eating or drinking or
peeing I know they couldn't do any of it
I didn't about that yeah that's probably
why you can't do it yeah are they gonna
piss I didn't think about that well
maybe the point was that then when they
got there there was going to be another
bus to bring them back so we're gonna
have to film it but we couldn't have a
crew so we're gonna have the company
like rig up a whole entire bus you could
do like a bus to Baltimore and the
alliteration helps a lot bustable the
bolt bus the balti bus and then you
don't need to worry about pissing and
eating yeah but it's not three hour
drive four hour drive we wanted it to be
excruciating remember put something on
the bus that makes it worse okay okay
are you looking for a writing job I mean
I'm I'm doing pretty good okay
yeah I know what I'm doing this guy's
going in Sicily seriously fungwa bus
lines remember fungwa bus lines in New
York absolutely bus lines
about this place Google
f-u-n-g Hua w-a-h bus lines they would
go from any City's Chinatown holy [ __ ]
any anybody so New York City's Chinatown
to Washington DC's Chinatown to Boston's
Chinatown to Baltimore any they would go
to from Chinatown to Chinatown for 1.99
was you could get a you can how do you
how is it Mega Bus Megabus did that but
this was but it was the precursor it was
fungwa bus line but what's the business
model there it was only between Boston
and New York that's it 96 of 2015. what
was the price and a brief period of 2014
it was shut down for safety violations
yes so they would have so by they would
have bus drivers
nobody nobody there were no um like two
dozen buses yeah you wouldn't have to
you wouldn't have to uh you know no
rules no Union rules it was all Chinese
immigrants coming over so they would
have them drive at 40 hours in a row the
buses were disgusting I took it to the
Boston County fence once it was the most
nerve-wracking experience I'd rather
take fentanyl than get on fungal bus
lines well that's that's sweet 2005 one
of them caught fire 2006 they one of
them flipped over 07 uh lost two of its
rear wheels oh my god oh seven uh hit a
guard rail on a Turnpike uh 07 again it
got stuck in a concrete but 07 was a
terrible
2008 uh there was they were struck by a
dump truck
what's worse things are the dump truck I
get now why it's 1.99 but no but really
though how do they sustain how is that a
business model I don't think it was I
think it was like probably like some
subsidized thing that has to be
something there has to be some way to
sustain that business it can't it can't
be a dollar 99 I don't know yeah how did
Megabus do a Megabus did the same thing
in Europe I took it when I was in Europe
I took Megabus from where I was staying
in the London and it had been it was I
think it was it was not it was 99 Cents
it was a pound one pound to get to
London and I never understood how they
did it I don't even remember what it
what maybe they up charge for the
bathroom or something or there was like
I don't remember what it was it's next
to free it is free like anyone I mean
literally a person that doesn't own a
home like anyone could get on it for a
dollar how long does it take to get to
Boston from here three and a half hours
so I guess they figure if they if they
can do three and a half four hours you
think it takes more than three or five
no no are you leaving five days at four
pm
[Laughter]
at some point it's like [ __ ] your
gadgets [ __ ] your [ __ ] your improvements
once you just learn to live with what
you got not everything needs to be
improved radically all the time even the
iPhones it's like just pick a version
and stay with it yeah just stop after
13. yeah or 12. whatever just shut not
everything needs to be constantly
updated one every five years
how about that yeah I mean or like why
does this urge to always get better at
stuff like just be content with what you
have like every generation's got to come
and how do I be the best how do I be
number one why do you have to be number
one do you know much pressure comes with
being number one that you tell every
every coach does every athlete you want
to be number one well I got to be number
one why why why why do you have to be
number one explain it explain the
benefits of being number one other than
unbelievable pressure a an exorbitant
amount of people now trying a gun for
you because they want to be number one
and then your ultimate fall from number
one
making you inevitably depressed because
we can only really try to stay in the
moment and if we're being coached all
the time stay in the moment stay in the
moment stay in the moment well there
will be a moment where you will fall to
number two and you'll be depressed had
you never been number one in the first
place you would be happier healthier and
probably alive longer because nobody
wants to take what you have heavy lie
the crown is this is is a saying that
exists for a reason you don't actually
want the crown when you try to come at
me with your
[ __ ]
about what something you are mimicking
that you heard some
professional speaker say on tick tock
about how you need to be the best and
how you got to be number one and how I
don't buy it you know why because I'm
happy with who I am I'm saying my meat
vessel that I'm carrying around today is
enough
yeah I I I took in everything you said
when you go to other countries
okay United Kingdom they don't act this
way it does give you a motivation though
they're striving for being the best that
kind of helps your like you excel in the
journey it's a motivator but and then I
and then there's also impure motivations
not necessarily and pure but people do
some stuff for money you got me I don't
know why I'm thinking of fighting now
Fighters striving to be the best and the
short self-license in the Fall From
Grace but you could apply to anything
but I'm thinking of of like UFC people
and stuff like that but you got to
strive to you got to be careful if you
want to try to do the best that's okay
but it has to be the best version of
yourself not better than someone else
you have to be the best you well that's
not how sport at least works
well maybe individual Olympic sport if I
was king of the world I'd cancel Sports
really yeah really it's out why why
especially you're a big fanatic I love
sports I just um you don't think it's a
please expound
I think that it's
dramatic it's impressive it's
competition it's
you know spirited you know it makes
money
it drives definitely you know helps City
evil true competition evil
so talk to me then tell me why
because entertaining
watching people do something at a high
level
competing
I think we're past it
as a people
I don't think we need to do it anymore
are you a lover of sports you're being
serious I think it's just the same thing
over and over and over again you win the
championship
then a month goes by and then you create
this fake thing again and then win a
thing that never mattered in the first
place again
it's just a waste of your time
you should be instead of playing sports
why not have all those athletes get out
there get Barefoot plug into the sand
right get on a higher consciousness
let's get on a higher level spiritually
it's fake I can understand if there was
one one time one time every 50 years
you're playing the sport and you know
it's going to give your continent the
the advantage to get water and food then
fine by all means but this thing it's
like what is the point of a season what
is the point oh you won the championship
in 2012 who cares it's irrelevant like I
just had a 38th 38th birthday who cares
but
it's irrelevant
you've been hanging out with them it's
irrelevant
um
I think when you're talking at least
about not necessarily exercising but
when you're talking about competitive
Sports they only exist through
competition
you know what so so they would that
would be wiped at your your eliminating
competition I believe right you know
what man let's bring back Sports
already I actually think after talking
it through what an idiotic idea it is to
cancel Sports
you need Sports
they promote a healthy lifestyle usually
promote a healthy lifestyle discipline
my daughter could use with some sports
people Bond over Sports the only sport
my daughter's good at right now is
crawling out of her crib and falling at
her onto her head is she the number one
hopefully one day she will be hopefully
one day she will be let's see what high
she can CL climb up and fall out of
Walt Disneyland tell me about it
oh yeah
like I don't know I've been there
Disneyland I believe
although it's fun for all ages
you get excited you get some endorphins
ultimately I don't know that it's leaves
our children
uh happier healthier and in better
condition from when they first went in I
think that
a rat race I think that things are
overpriced I think that
it puts children into a space of
like this reality that's kind of not
what they'll grow up in
but what about just creativity and
fantasy and fun
I don't I don't think going to
Disneyland
I think
I think
the ultimate thing you can do for your
kids and be completely selfless is
taking them to Disneyland I don't think
that it gets any harder on a parent than
taking children multiple children under
the age of seven to Disneyland it sounds
like I don't think it gets any harder
than that it sounds torturous it sounds
insane I I'm as impressed with that as
the guy who's drawn sculptures on rice
you think that's one and the same pretty
much
pretty much
I guess I can't really it sounds like
hell I guess I can't articulate why I
don't like Disneyland I was able to do
it a couple hours ago but now I can't
I just can't tell you why I don't like
it okay but I'm I guess I could say that
I'm happy my kids liked it but what I am
actually proud of is that we told my
kids that we were going to take them
back to Disneyland two times in one week
we're gonna take them back to Disneyland
if they listened and then they didn't
listen that night and then we actually
followed through and took Disneyland
away from them and they I agree and they
cried
for five minutes and then we told them
Disneyland is gone but not your day so
you kids can go in the pool and have fun
there and then they jump for joy put in
their bathing suits and stayed in the
pool for 12 hours right so you kind of
realize your kids never they don't need
Disneyland right Disneyland needs them
yes
it's true and also maybe I think a lot
of people a lot of people are living
vicariously like they're like let's go
to Disneyland because they want to go to
Disneyland
yeah I would say that the most problems
when I was at Disneyland was my family
were the adults not agreeing over what
section of the park they thought they
said the kids wanted to go to AKA what
part do you want to go to right yes okay
yep
what was your favorite part of
Disneyland yeah Space Mountain
space that's the roller coaster in the
dark right fully in the dark yeah Space
Mountain and then also going into the
Galaxy ride phenomenal it's in the Old
Tower of Terror uh 3D thing let me no no
I'm not kidding on the screen and then
it goes up goes down my daughter was
screaming she didn't know when we were
waiting online she's not understanding
the physics of it yeah she goes is there
a drop I was like it's a little one
because I thought that it was and then
it shoots you 200 feet into the air at
the speed of light rather it brings you
right back down I'm not lying this is
100 true I told this pimp teacher was
there even my daughter someone in our
ride in our cubicle fully [ __ ] their
pants
no no a full [ __ ] on the floor out of
their shorts I on my children they fully
[ __ ] in their pants when you got out of
the ride the woman opened the door she
goes she goes all right guys you know
that was whatever Guardians of the
Galaxy and then slowly put her mask up I
swear because they all were wearing
covert mess but she he fully 100 [ __ ] in
his pants and you know Jerry was with it
she goes oh my God he goes I think
somebody [ __ ] their pants
TT Jerry and then Delilah was Delilah
was like Daddy it stinks and everyone
was and everyone was getting off the
ride I swear to God except these two men
sitting all the way in the corner of one
of of one part of the right because you
go in with like 12 people but it was a
full [ __ ] in the past wow
that's unbelievable it was and it was
not a fart it was an undoubted undoubted
no but you saw the two men sitting in
the corner I think they were a gay
couple two men sitting in the corner
um not moving and you knew that there
was [ __ ] in that you know you could tell
you could just tell yeah yeah and how I
also know it was [ __ ] in the pants
because the way you come out you can see
the line which the line is put is moving
pretty constantly yeah because you can
fit so many people and they got and the
line was at a complete stop
what does that mean because they had to
clean the [ __ ] off the floor before they
could load more people so the line was
out of completely you're convinced that
not only did he [ __ ] but the [ __ ] fell
out of his pants he shut down the ride
there's no way no he [ __ ] his pants and
and me and Jerry and my daughter and my
stepson were kind of like being like was
that a fart and it was it was fully [ __ ]
out of his ass down is like on according
to the Galaxy
Guardians of the Galaxy
what is did a tourist get diarrhea on a
roller coaster at the splash 14 people
oh God I I would have to think I would
have to think if I went on a roller
coaster and somebody diarrhea [ __ ] in my
face and I had waited two hours at what
point do you just you have to kind of
make a split decision and say well I
can't get out of this so I might as well
just enjoy the ride
and just like the diarrhea don't try to
move out of the way just keep your mouth
shut yeah just and just try to get
whatever you can for them close your
eyes and just let it kind of happen
that is the most Zen that's that's the
the most advanced way of looking at that
situation that's what the Mayans would
do that's what they would do that's what
they would do oh man well
well you know what it's been this has
been
hey babe don't be a fake don't be a
flake don't run away from your feelings
babe don't be afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey babe
[Music]